Morning everybody. I would say good
morning but as I've said to several of
you already I don't do morning in my own
time zone which is the west coast. So
I'll make you a deal. I will try to stay
upright and awake if you do and if I
start to see people falling asleep I'm
going back to my chair and taking a nap
until noon. So I'm really here wearing
two hats: the first is as a faculty
member at Washington State University,
I'm a neuroscientist, and the second is
as the president of Science Talk, which
is a science communication nonprofit and
at Science Talk, our goal is to bring
together not just this community but the
community of science communication
facilitators and practitioners around
the country to continue to form these
communities to exchange best practices
and to really grow our impact nationwide.
What so just a shameless plug there that
our next conference is April 4th and 5th
in Portland and I have some postcards
out on the back table. But today I'm here
at least for this talk in primarily my
role as a faculty member to talk a bit
about some of the barriers to engaging
in outreach and that's what Jeanne really
asked me to address today. So I'll just
talk about three, not saying that there
are only three barriers, but in a short
period of time these are the three that
I want to touch on: the barrier of the
lack of incentive, the lack of
encouragement, and the lack of
opportunity and again I probably will be
raising more questions than I have
answers but that seems to be a general
theme for the conference; let's ask a
bunch of questions and then apparently
they'll put us at tables later and we're
all supposed to come up with the answers
to save the world. So let's start with a
lack of incentive. I think for a lot of
faculty this comes down to and I might
be dating myself here the phrase the
Sagan effect. Anybody heard of that? Right
anybody know who Carl Sagan is or was?
Right most of the group. Right so there's
an urban legend that I think has some
truth to it that says that Carl Sagan
was not elected to the National
Academies because he was a public
intellectual,
that his scholarship was just as good as
those who were elected but he was
shunned because he was seen as too much
of a communicator and not as much of a
serious scientist like you can't be both
and I think that this permeates a lot of
academic culture. Yes, that was decades
ago but there's still this concern that
if you're seen as too much of a public
figure you must not be serious in the
field or in the lab and I think this
really manifests not just in that fear
of ostracization by colleagues but in
the lack of incentive in the formal
process and for those of us that are
faculty that's T&P: tenure and promotion.
When we're hired in an institution, we're
told there are three things that your
T&P is riding on: your research, your
teaching, and your service. It's a
three-legged stool and we're told make
it a wobbly stool. It should be research
first, then teaching, and then over here a
little bit of wobbly service just enough
to get by so that your colleagues know
who you are. Outreach is never in there.
If it is it's shunted into that shorter
third leg of service. I have colleagues
who've been told at major research
institutions "don't be too good a teacher
or you won't get tenure". Right, the
educators in here are appalled
so is this colleague but it was the
reality. Even if his scholarship was that
good
often it's the same with engagement. if we're going to change this and incentivize faculty who are already
interested or on the fence we need to
include public outreach as part of the
tenure and promotion criteria. At my own
institution at Washington State
University, I wasn't actively prohibited or
discouraged. I wasn't encouraged either.
Basically I was told have good
scholarship, be a good teacher, do some service work and we'll kind of ignore whatever
else you want to do. At least that was my
attitude. They never really told me that
and I just decided to go for it and
do things like found a non-profit before
I was tenured and thankfully it didn't
get in my way but that's not true
everywhere. The culture's starting to
change.
So at University of Washington our
in-state rival school, I saw a 22-point
list of barriers to engaging in outreach
and recommendations for overcoming those
barriers which was really nice to see.
Some of these were things like changing
the indirect cost structure so that for
grants that involve an outreach
component they're not charged that 50%
or 60% overhead that a lot of smaller
foundations just won't pay. The other was
to include outreach in the formal tenure
and promotion criteria to make it a four
legged stool and I think that's going to
make a huge difference. I also think
that's going to help level the playing
field a little bit. If we think about the
scientists that engage in outreach more
broadly and looking around this room and
this meeting it's primarily women and we
know that the studies say that women on
average tend to engage more in outreach
than men and women on average are
promoted at least to full professor at a
lower rate than men. Are those correlated?
Well correlated yes. Is there is it
causitive? No idea but one could assume
that it might be so by incentivizing
outreach we can level that playing field
and invite both women and men to the
table and reward us for that. The second
barrier is the lack of encouragement and
I see this differently than incentive
because the incentive is that formal
structure. The encouragement is somebody saying yeah go for it and I think this
is particularly important for trainees
for our students and postdocs. For those
that were at the story collider last night
you heard Kristin talked about her
experience as a graduate student
engaging in outreach basically to save
her soul during grad school and that's not
uncommon. So often we need to get out of
the lab and actually engage to rekindle our
own excitement for science and to share
that with others but if we're not
encouraged by our PI or by our
department or our institution we're less
likely to do that or if we do engage
we're more likely to hide it. At Science
Talk we offer travel awards for trainees
to attend our conference and I so often
get letters that say please give me
money to attend because I can't even
tell my PI that I want to do this. Right
so sometimes the PI doesn't have money
to support that attendance in a monetary
way but they could still say yeah this
is a great idea let me help you find
institutional funds but if the student
is too afraid to go to their PI and say
I'm interested in engaging in outreach
and improving my communication skills.
That's a huge barrier to overcome. The
other thing is, as I think all of us in
here know, that old model of the faculty
member mentoring their trainees to be
clones of ourselves is complete BS
because those aren't the jobs that are
available and those aren't the jobs that
most of the students and postdocs want.
Communication skills and engagement are key but if we're not encouraging those
skills then we're not helping the next
generation of scientists develop their
full potential and I know that I'm
preaching to the choir here already. I
probably don't need to say that but I
think it's important for us to think
about so we can go back and talk to our
institutions about why they need to
support this and encourage this
engagement and not just our institutions
but our colleagues and especially for
the faculty members and the
administrators in here it's really up to
us to stand up for all of our right to
engage in outreach. So thinking back
again dating myself that whole fight for
your right to party. Right, fight for your
right to engage because it's important!
Right somebody else about my age exactly
and finally the third barrier is the
lack of opportunity really the lack of
connection to opportunity. There are so
many great opportunities out there:
science cafes and nerd
nights and taste of science festivals and
all kinds of things I'm not mentioning
that all of you are involved in and a
lot that I didn't even know about until
yesterday. While yes I spend a lot of
time locked in my lab I'm fairly active
in the science communication outreach
community and I hadn't heard of a lot of
these great opportunities so what about
the scientists who aren't as active but
want to engage and don't know where to start?
That's where we need a pipeline and as
was already said in the introduction
that really starts at our home
institutions. We have biology programs,
math programs, english programs, we have
offices of student engagement and
student affairs. Why is it not standard
to have offices of outreach and
engagement? That's again starting to
change. There are programs here at
Rockefeller, there are programs at Duke,
there are programs at Harvard, there are
programs in many places that again I
apologize if I'm not mentioning yours
but those are still a one-of rather than
expected and I get that science
engagement outreach is still new enough
that everybody thinks they should create
something new and shiny
rather than yet another office that does
the same thing as University X over here.
But not every math program thinks it has
to be new and shiny and different.
Everybody thinks we need a solid math
program, we need a solid biology program,
we need an office of Student Affairs. Why
not make an office of engagement and
outreach just as standard? Now this also
gets to a comment that was mentioned in
the introduction which is funding those
offices. It's much easier to fund a new,
shiny this is gonna change the world
initiative then yet another one of the
same and I get that. I don't have the
answer there other than we need to talk
to our donors, we need to talk to our
foundation offices, and we need the
scientists who are trained to be in
front of those donors saying this is why
this matters and this is why you should
give to this program at my institution
or in my community. Because it is this
important not just to have a new and different program everywhere but to have
iterations of similar programs across
the country. So I think that's really it.
Well, not all of it, but as I said what
I'm going to address here which is that
lack of incentive, that lack of
encouragement, and that lack of a
pipeline to opportunity and I'll end
there in that speaking specifically as a
bench scientist at the end of the day
we're busy. I'm in my lab and more to the
point I'm in my office writing grants so
that the people in my lab can actually
do the work. We want to engage but we're
not going to search for the
opportunities as much as we're going to
take advantage of the opportunities that
are easier to connect to so if we can
make those connections I think we're
really going to encourage and foster
engagement.
Thanks so much! That was actually a really inspiring talk. I would love to know your perspective
about new professors coming into the
department versus tenured, have been
there 20, 30, 40 years and their outlook
on outreach and engagement.
Well it depends on the professor but I would say on average those that have been there 20,
30, 40 years don't see the point of
engagement and are more likely to
discourage it. Occasionally you find
those kind of bright shining lights that
have been there forever and maybe didn't
do it themselves but think yes this is
great. We'll encourage you. I think we're
seeing that it's a lot more common in
younger faculty that are really
interested in engagement and that's
where I think we need that institutional
incentive for tenure and promotion. Like
I said I did it anyway and said screw it
watch this but that wasn't going to work
if I was at a different institution with
even higher expectations for scholarship.
I'm gonna follow up on that.
Thank you for the leading because it was
exactly what I was gonna ask. So people
are gonna roll my eyes because I make this
point every time I'm at a conference and
yeah Jeanne will be one of them.
So you do this and you say there other
people do this. Should every faculty member
be required to do this? Should this be
mandatory? No. Why not? Have you been to a
scientific conference lately? There are
people you don't want out talking to the public.
So I'm gonna I'm gonna absolutely
disagree with you. Talking with the
public can mean a whole host of things.
You talked about your Skype a scientist, I'm
sure you have a whole range of people
who would not necessarily be great going
to a 6th grade 6th grade classroom or
giving a science cafe. You know what you
can edit a Wikipedia article. That's
outreach. That's engaging with the public.
You can go there are all different
formats so I strongly disagree with the
notion that not everyone should be doing
this and I think this gets to your point
of culture change. If you're saying well
you don't have to do it only some of us
are gonna do it the culture is never
gonna change it's just going to be a
select few that are always doing it. But
if it's mandatory, if it's something that
is expected of everyone no matter
there's different formats, that's where
you're gonna get the culture change.
That's a good point I think my own bias
is because I also teach oral
communication of science and so I think
my own bias is very much thinking about
outreach and engagement as face-to-face
communication and oral interaction
conversation and I vehemently think that
not all scientists should engage in that
but when you expand the definition to
things like editing a Wikipedia article
or something then yes actually I do
agree with you.